Good afternoon, Tina.
You're on mute, yeah.
I'm muted. Hey, yeah, how's it going?
Going good, how about you?
Doing well, doing well.
Great. So, Tanner, I guess we met, I think it was when we first onboarded Casey. That was the time when I ran the onboarding call. So I clearly remember that. Not sure if you do. I, yeah, thank you so much. So I'm here, you know.
The.
Yeah, I do.
just to take the feedback about Casey, because Kip has met with a family emergency. Actually, his mother passed away last week, so he is at his hometown. And so, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Ohh.
Boot.
That's right. So he would be here next week, but we wanted to give him this time to be with his family and thought of covering in for him when he's away.
Yeah, that's too bad.
Absolutely, yeah. No, that's too bad.
The.
Right.
Yeah.
You.
Nice. Yeah, no, so things are going well with Casey. He's staying busy. We have a lot of projects going on and stuff. And so, yeah, I mean, we have nothing but good things with going on with Casey and his communication with us is great. And I would say, yeah, at this point, there's not really anything I would
Yeah.
narrow down to say he needs to work on it. I think he's overall doing a really good job.
Thank you so much for sharing that. And Tanner, did you receive the seaside survey for the month of May?
No, I can search for it though.
Let's see.
Um...
See here.
See, I don't see it.
Start it.
Let me see if I can resend it.
If you can resend it, I'll do the survey right now. That'd be great.
I'm trying to do, yeah.
Excuse me.
I...
Was able to hang out with your team for a while. We were up at Pac State Beyond in Salt Lake City last week. So yeah, I met with, Natalie was there and she was with, gosh, I can't think of his name.
Oh, wow.
Vikram Ankur.
Yes, yep, that was it. We hung out and went out for a while and...
Add some.
Had some drinks, it was a fun time.
Well, that's great. You liked it. I have just resent the survey, so you should have it either with that or two.
Sweet.
Thank you.
We're hoping we kind of talked about a little bit while we were there going to your guys's
AI event in August, so yeah, we're...
I mastermind you.
It's build ID, yes. So I guess you have not registered yet for build it.
No, no, Natalie was trying to figure out some free tickets she was going to send us, but...
Haven't heard back yet, so she said I need to reach out to you guys too, but we'll see. I don't know. I'd love to go, but...
Oh, okay.
I'll follow up with her.
New York's kind of a hard spot for us to get to, yeah.
I know, that's why every every bad thing happens to New York first, right?
Yeah, yep. So yeah, I did get the CSAT and I just submitted the.
Thank you.
S.
We have, okay, great.
Positive feedback form.
I appreciate it. Thank you, Tanner. Before I jump into the presentation deck, anything that you want to share about Casey that we should be aware of?
No, yeah, nothing but nothing but good things about him.
Thank you. Let me go ahead and share my screen.
Let me know, Tina, if you are able to see it.
Yep, I can see it.
Thank you. So this is our monthly business review and review duration is May 18th till June 12th.
Let's start off with our agenda items for today, which remains the same. We have our check-in, we have highlights of the account, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of the customer, pay forward, and then recap.
So how are things at this moment? We have already covered this. So I'll skip this slide. These are the discussion points from a previous Connect, where we have received good feedback for Casey. His ownership, proactive engagement, and project execution was appreciated. Utilization was 82%.
Mhm.
for the last month. I think Kip also spoke about if you're interested in having additional resource, so that was a no at that time. The KPI framework for Casey on delivery, quality, stakeholder satisfaction. I hope Casey is meeting all the expectations in terms of the KPIs.
Yep.
Yeah, he is.
Thank you.
And the certification for AZ104. So I had a word with Casey. His training is completed. He is due to complete his exam. I will check with him and will share if he has any data in mind yet.
Nice. What do you guys do for, like when you have all of your techs like that, that are doing certifications for your company like that, do you guys have like one big portal that they all go through? Do you guys, how do you monitor their progress or how do you guys do all of that?
Great. So we have a career development plan, we call it CDPs in ITBD by design. So there is a quarterly discussion that takes place with the reporting manager of an individual where we, you know, glance through what engineer did in the past three months.
and where do they see themselves on the basis of the technologies and tickets they are working on with their current partner, where do they see themselves growing technically. If they want to achieve certain certification, they would write it and there has to be a milestone against that particular certification. Like in a month, they should have at least 30% of the course completion.
And on the monthly connect, the respective manager is bound to check with the engineer if he or she is there yet. If it is on track, if it is off track, if on track, good. If it's off track, then what were the reasons? What help they need from the reporting manager to put them back on track?
And once the certification is completed, and obviously they will get the required work from the relevant technology. So this is from the certification site. We also have engineers who are working for horizontal or vertical promotions. You know, someone wants to be in a team lead position. So that is something you cannot achieve in 1/4. For that, you need at least three quarters or a year.
Mhm.
So intentionally engineer would work in this zone. They would gradually help their existing manager with the supporting team. And obviously, before you qualify for this role, you need to have certain prerequisites that has to be checked by the reporting manager. So things like that, we have multiple programs that continuously go on.
Right.
throughout your organization and prospective managers are there to keep a check.
Sure. Yeah, no, I like that. The reason I ask is we're trying to roll some of that out for internal texts because I was impressed how you guys keep Casey doing these certifications and he always hits them and you have a really good plan with his certs. What do you do? What do you do, I guess, if someone...
Mm.
in your company isn't at 30% at the meeting mark where you're supposed to be at 30% to be on track to be done with it that quarter. What if you have, do you have tax ever that just don't do those certs when they're saying they're supposed to be?
There are, there are subjects, you know, who are not able to do it in there in the desired mark, so if it is required, we can extend it to the next quarter.
Mhm.
But certainly that would that would hit their their scorecard for that particular quarter, because that that that has that has a big KPI mark for for that relevant quarter, and if engineer is able to, if he's not able to achieve it, then obviously they'll get a dent on their scorecard.
Sure.
Yeah, then it reflects back to basically their reviews, because yeah, that should be a huge section of that scorecard. So yeah, no, I like that framework. That's nice.
Absolutely.
Engineers completely accountable for it, because since we are in a in a co-managed model, so engineers work with their managers, so it is manager's responsibility to talk to the engineer in their weekly and monthly connects, like where you are.
Mhm.
So we don't wait for engineer to tell us on 90th day that, hey, I could not do it. They have to let us know at least on 20th or 30th day that I'm already behind what I'm expected to achieve by then. Yes.
Falling behind, yeah. Sure. It's up to them to say that. Okay, yeah, that's good.
So if it is a change in strategy or some internal trainings are required. So that is something that is a separate topic that we continue.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, no, that's good. That's good feedback. Thank you. We've had issues where, yeah, we want people to do certs and even tell them, yeah, we'll pay for them. And it's just, yeah, it's hard to find time for them to do them, even though you allocate that time. So.
The.
Yeah.
So on the similar lines, we have our internal to, I don't know, Kip spoke to you about, is that Team GPS. So we have all the records of individuals there. So if someone has achieved A certification, that genius name is highlighted for a certain amount of time, and everyone in the organization would see it.
which gives them motivation to do in their line of business. And it will give morale to the current engineer as well to do more and get more certifications. So it's not something that you have to keep on doing certification, certification, no, you have to gain knowledge as well. So if you are certified in certain technology, that does not mean that you go for the
Yeah.
subsequent technology now. You first get your hands on, get your hands dirty with this technology. If you're over with it, then you go for the next one.
Okay, cool.
Nice.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, no, sorry to get you off topic there. I was just, yeah, kind of wanted to see what was going on.
Thank you.
No, no, no, it's completely fine.
Alright, so these were the KPIs I guess Kip spoke to you about on time delivery rate, on budget delivery, rework rate, documentation quality, and stakeholder satisfaction. So...
Tanner, do you think that Casey is on track with all of these KPIs for the month of May?
I do, yeah. No, I think he stays on track for that for sure.
All right. Thank you.
Moving on to performance analysis. This is the utilization trend for Casey. So in the first week, as per the graph, May 18th till 22nd, his available had been 95 percent, which is the highest of all the four weeks. We could see a dip, progressive, you know,
But the second week, he was at 77%. That's the day, that's the week where he was on PTO. One was because of Memorial Day, the holiday, and another was the planned leave. However, if we see towards the end of the month, you know, beginning of June,
Mhm.
Yeah.
His utilization keeps on dipping to 65 and then to 43 percent. I had a connect with Casey, so I think this is where we have limited work because of which his utilization lipped. But just wanted to understand, Chandan, from your perspective, do you have any inputs, this one?
Yeah, and a lot of the reason for that dip at the end there was he has like 3 projects that we're working on right now that are at a standstill because he's doing a lot of investigating where he needs to go with it. And so I can see where he'd still be busy, but that dip is there. So I'm not worried about it. But yeah, he has like
Mhm.
a couple projects now that are just kind of at a standstill for him until we can get more information.
Thank you.
Next is the tickets closure. So although closure rate is less, so Casey being someone who works on projects and escalated tickets, so the amount of tickets he's working on are subsequently higher than the tickets he's closing. He worked on 130 tickets in
In the four weeks, and could close thirty-nine, making his closure rate somewhere around 40%, so...
Let me know, Tether, if you have any questions or any concerns there.
Nope, that looks good.
Thank you so much.
Okay, way forward. Casey Deepak will reach out when he has less tickets to work on. I think he's doing it already. I'll skip this one. So build it. We have spoke about it already. I'll connect with Natalie and keep you posted.
Yeah, let me know. We'd love to go, but...
Yeah.
See what you can do for us on that.
Yeah, the New York thing, I know.
Yeah, it's hard to hard to get clear across the states for us, as you know, but...
Okay.
I do. All right, so this is our team GPS. So this was the forum that I was talking about, the internal tool that we have built where we have, you know, the place, the forum where we have appreciation for the team members. And other than that, we have like group meetings.
the discussions that you have with your team members. You can keep the notes, you can refer back to your notes, what they said, what you told them. The RNR can be kept here, employee engagement, client engagement. This is where we get the CSAR surveys that you have just filled. And we have the strategic goal alignment. This is where we
work with the engineers on their future goals in terms of the certifications, level ups, and internal promotions.
Kour.
What are we? I, what are we? What would we benefit from that? I guess what I guess what something we could use that for? Is it something we should be doing? Or I see you say request a demo and stuff, but I guess I don't really get the benefit of that for us.
So, what you can, so did you already have the demo?
I'm sure we did. I'm sure Dylan did or something.
So like I said, a few of the points that I have already explained to you. So when you start using this tool, you explore it, there is a huge potential. At the same time, the team that has developed a team GPS is in-house to IT by design. So anything that you want to customize, you know,
anything, any performance management tool that you might be using internally, some of the features that you feel like that are best suited to your organization needs, that you want those features to be included to your specific access, that can also be done.
Oh, sure.
So we bring our whole team, we bring our whole team into this. This isn't just something with Casey. Okay, I gotcha.
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
Yep.
This would be for our entire team.
Yes, and you can also reward them for their good work. Suppose if they have worked on multiple escalated tickets, worked with a furious user, converted in convert this furious user into a person who gave positive or appreciated feedback, things of such nature.
are meant to be rewarded, so you can internally reward your team members accordingly.
Mhm.
So you guys use this internally and then you're basically selling it for, you're letting other people use it as well as their own tenant. Okay, I got you. What is your guys' price structure on it roughly?
We do.
It's.
Yep.
This is something that I'm not aware of. So, yep.
You're good. It'll probably tell you in the demo and stuff. Sure. OK, that makes that makes sense. OK.
Absolutely, yeah.
So would you like me to book a demo for it or have someone reach out to you?
Um, that's okay. Maybe I build it. I'll talk to someone on it.
Okay, makes sense.
Talk to Natalie sometime on it.
Absolutely. All right. Is there anything else, Tanner, you want to share, talk about?
Kour.
Sweet.
No, that's it. Yeah, no, thanks for, thanks for going over all that with me, and it was, it was helpful. So, yeah, no, that's all I got.
Thank you so much. So I will share this deck in an email. You can go through it. And yeah, it was nice talking to you after, I think, eight or nine months. Looking forward to talk to you again. And yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, if you see, if you see Kip around the office in the meantime, let him know we're thinking about him and sorry to hear about his mom.
You, please.
Yeah, sure, I will, and I appreciate it. Thank you so much. Yeah, have a great day, Tina, and see you soon. Bye.
Yep.
All right.
Yep, you as well. Thanks, bye.